denis noël qui sont nombreux vides dont
les filles je veux pas en faire tout un
plat mais j'ai mon premier en caractère
de père noël qui sur scène ou non sans
déconner avec lequel
[Applaudissements]
oh mais il a connu comment j'ai pu
laisser burnes
c'est romantique on en apprend un match
sous les mecs quand les épis leur bien à
plat qui pleure et plaques qui s'la joue
gros dur la nuit il était si calme
c'était comme des pelles et les bureaux
du dalaï lama et toi comment ça se passe
avec ta mère assez drôle c mais je crois
que ça va mais c'est ça va enfin je suis
crois oui ma mère s'est fait faire la
même couleur et la même coupe que la
mienne mais je crois que c'est presque
normal
et est ce que vos mères à vous est-ce
que vos mamans poche tu veux que je te
dise
chaque fois que je pense que je suis la
plus cinglés notre groupe qui tu ouvre
la bouche et là je me dis non je vais
très bien
[Musique]